hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain an american
fantasy and drama movie called i kill
giants
the movie begins with a girl named
barbara thorsen who comes into the
forest
she picks up mushroom spores to mix into
her potion
not long after she hears the sound of
someone approaching him
thus she tidies up her belongings and
immediately leaves the place besides
that she makes a decoy using the potions
he just made
when she monitors the bait from afar she
is very surprised because there is a
giant hand that approaches the bait
arriving home she notes in her journal
that the potion he made earlier has
succeeded in luring the giant to come
out
she lives independently with her brother
dave and her older sister karen
the next morning she is annoyed by dave
because he is very noisy while playing
video games with his friends therefore
barbara immediately turns off the video
game as he ignores her an angry dave
takes her dice and throws them at the
food which kieran just made
after a while barbara takes out her
homemade binoculars to look at the sea
unexpectedly she sees a fairly large
whirlpool
out of curiosity she wants to take a
closer look at it but unfortunately the
whirlpool has disappeared
when she enters the house she overhears
dave's conversation saying that she is
crazy feeling hurt she ends up going to
her base camp in the basement
she listens to the radio while sewing
her bag
unluckily her finger is punctured with
the needle
she then smeared her blood on her bag
while chanting a spell
afterwards she goes to the kitchen to
pick up the leftovers with the intention
of hanging them on a pole somewhere near
the sea
soon she goes to the abandoned train
yard
there she draws symbols on the railway
wagon
one day she goes to the beach and meets
sophia a girl who just moved to the area
she immediately expresses an interest in
getting to know barbara but sadly
barbara initially remains aloof
when she returns home she
unintentionally sees her sister on the
phone
looks like karen has some problems at
work but then she leaves because there's
nothing she can do about it
on the next day while she is waiting for
the school bus she sees a bad woman
being conveyed by a flock of pigeons
suddenly sophia comes and takes
barbara's binoculars to look at what
she's looking at
when the school bus arrives she asks
barbara to sit next to her because she
only knows barbara but then again she
refuses and goes to sit in the back of
the bus instead
at the school barbara checks the tallest
man she has made beforehand meanwhile
one of the teachers quietly follows her
from behind as she notices barbara
behaving strangely
in the toilet barbara finds another
ominous sign in the drain under the wash
stand
on the other hand the teacher finds a
strange symbol engraved on the wooden
door
she then decides to go inside at the
same time with barbara who is about to
come out of the toilet it is revealed
that barbara covers the broken drain
with a duct tape
during break time barbara is approached
by a group of bullies led by taylor
because of it a confrontation breaks out
between them but fortunately is
interrupted by the school psychologist
mrs mole who calls for barbara to come
to her room she asks barbara about her
likes and dislikes but then she leaves
the meeting abruptly declaring that
their talk will just distract her from
her preparations to battle a giant
later she has been confronted again by
taylor just at the right time sofia
calls the principal to help barbara
after that the two walk together at the
beach
barbara invites sofia to come to her
base camp called the holy sanctuary
she then explains the mythology behind
the giants to sophia
in the past all the giants were
descendants of ur the first giant who
was the misbegotten son of the earth and
sky
er gave birth to giants on earth there
were the first king of the earth frost
giants swamp giants mountain giants and
harbingers in which where there is a
harbinger there is also a giant nearby
the last one is titan the biggest and
most terrible giant
after that she shows sophia the baits
and traps which she created to her and
trapped giants
she also tells her about the magical
warhammer called the koveleski which she
keeps in her handbag to find and kill
the giants
the following day mrs maul invites
barbara back to her room to find out
more about her but it all seems hopeless
when she keeps talking and showing her
journal about the giants
during baseball barbara suddenly invites
sophia to haunt a giant but she reviews
this because she does not want to get
into trouble at the same time the
teacher does not allow her to leave
causing her to insult the teacher's work
consequently she is suspended for one
week by the principal for insulting the
baseball teacher
even so she is still happy to get a
letter from sophia apologizing to her
on her way to meet sophia barbara opens
her hand back to store the letter
surprisingly there's a red light coming
out of the bag
she then apologizes because she opened
the bag for a different purpose
eventually the light goes off and she
rushes out to haunt giant
as sophia sees barbara run she then
approaches and follows her to hunt the
giant however sophie begins to doubt
barbara's claims about the giants
because they cannot find the giants
there she then goes first leaving
barbara behind
suddenly a harbinger approaches barbara
but she just stands in silence in shock
because of this she asks sophia for her
blood to protect her from the harbingers
soon mrs maul asks barbara about her
interest in baseball unexpectedly the
question makes her feel sad because she
remembers her past
feeling depressed she becomes lost in
her bad memories causing her to slap mrs
maul and run straight to her home as she
continues to think about the previous
question in a days she is startled by
sophia and then reflexively strikes her
because of that taylor and her friends
also laugh at her even though barbara
tries to apologize sofia runs off
later sophia is approached by taylor who
promises to tell a secret about barbara
if she is willing to show them some of
the freaky things barbara has been doing
all along
sofia agrees about it leading taylor and
her friends to the holy sanctuary they
proceed to dismantle all of barbara's
traps knowing this barbara interrupts
them and immediately takes out kovileski
which turns out to be the jawbone of a
small animal tied to a stick
she's shocked by the state of her gun
and then she is beaten by taylor and her
friends
sophia then takes barbara to barbara's
home to recover when she wakes up she
becomes very upset at being brought
upstairs then she sees sophia who is
scared looking into one of the bedrooms
she then tells sophia to slowly walk
away for something called it sees her
sofia drops a glass of water in shock
before fleeing the house after that
barbara visits mrs mole at her house
looking for help but she grows
uncomfortable upon being introduced to
her family and she runs back into the
forest
since that incident barbara has
disappeared and has not gone to school
for a few days
on the other side she sets some traps to
fight the giants alone
back to sofia who never sees barbara
again she and mrs small eventually visit
barbara's house
in the basement sophia discovers a
recording of barbara and her mother
telling the story of kovalevsky's
nickname the giant killer
with that information sophia leaves the
house and finally finds barbara at first
barbara gets angry with her because her
kovalevsky was broken and she feels that
sofia has betrayed her meanwhile sophia
keeps telling her that all of the giants
are in her head and asks her about why
she never talks about her mother even
though barbara shuts out the question
and she is unable to hear it barbara
angrily storms off and slams the table
outside she is approached again by
harbingers who taunt her saying that she
is too weak to defeat a giant
therefore barbara heads to face the
giant at the abandoned trainer she hides
in the trains but she keeps being hunted
by the giant
she ends up activating a train control
station rigged to a nearby electrical
pulse which electrocutes it and sets
some of the train cars on fire
unluckily sofia arrives just as barbara
is about to leave the next day an
unexpected storm bears down on the town
just then karen receives a call from mrs
mall who is looking for barbara
she also says that barbara has
humiliated taylor by placing a skeleton
in her locker
at the same time barbara discovers that
she still cannot use kobeleski as she
prays for the return of her weapon
shortly after mrs small manages to
confront barbara on her way to the
sanctuary saying that her mother is
seriously ill and is eager to see her
sadly barbara chooses to ignore the
explanation
meanwhile taylor comes to barbara's
secret hideout and destroys all of
barbara's belongings as sophia tries to
stop her after destroying the hideout
taylor leaves the area
a few moments later barbara arrives at
the area as she looks at the sea a titan
suddenly appears barbara immediately
stands against it and draws forth to
restore kovaleski from her handbag
revealing a massive and glowing
warhammer
fueled by her wrath because she thinks
that the titan came for her mother she
proceeds to defeat the titan with it
lying injured on the beach the titan
reveals that he actually came for
barbara not for her mother barbara is
stunned by its statement and then she
demands the titan to finish it off the
titan snatches her up and draws her
close to its head so she can strike it
down with koveleski as the giant falls
back into the ocean it brings barbara
with it sinking below the waves she
hears the voice of the giant telling her
that every living thing must die it also
says to run from death is to reject life
and that she must find joy in every
moment while she can
feeling motivated to live again barbara
swims back to the beach where she
finally can reunite with sophia
soon barbara climbs upstairs to see it
which turns out to be her mother who
lies dying in her bed
they share heartfelt messages and
barbara apologizes for avoiding her all
this time after summer vacation
barbara's mother dies but barbara is
able to rekindle her relationships with
mrs mole karen and sophia
on her first night of school she is
awakened by the titan who stands in the
ocean and watches her from afar
lastly she says thank you and goes back
to sleep peacefully
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching